hey man I'm Kevin Smith hey everybody
I'm Pete Holmes tabash Maniscalco yo
what up I'm Nick Cannon my name is Tim
Meadows yo I'm Romeo Miller hi I'm
Andrea Savage
Dean winters Jesse McCartney I'm Ron
Funches
I'm KFC I am phyla burger the last seven
years we've been doing our podcast KFC
radio compiling the craziest questions
the Internet has to offer now we are
putting celebrities to the test to put
them in the hot seat and making them
squirm with just just the most
outrageous things ever said to them this
is answer the internet how long would it
take you to drink all of the water and
an above-ground pool I see six would you
rather do the first 90% of a [__] or
the last 10%
you guys are sick [__] I just gotta say
do you think there's more porn stars or
murders in the world I refuse would you
take four million dollars to be on To
Catch a Predator why do I have to do
this would you rather have a good hand
job from your grandma good god guys or a
bad hand job for your grandmother oh I
wanna know who wrote this [__]